wow that was fast Resident Evil 3 so
Resident Evil three the remake is that's
right it's the remake of resident evil 3
nemesis sometimes it's all in the title
friends just like Resident Evil 2 last
year was a remake of Resident Evil 2 for
the PlayStation the events take place at
the same time as Resident Evil 2 this
time you play as Jill Valentine from
Resident Evil 1 you play as her trying
to escape from Raccoon City as Raccoon
City is just burning to the ground a
zombies are rising only umbrella has
dropped a new monster called the nemesis
to hunt her down right let the mayhem
begin so what I liked about this game is
first of all but it starts out it is
intense if you played the Resident Evil
2 remake you know this game is gonna
look impressive I believe it's built off
of the same engine some impressive
graphics impressive mood impressive mood
lighting by mood lighting I mean you
know we're all gonna die kind of shed
basic atmosphere and tone the game looks
great as Resident Evil 2 did and had a
point in the intro when you're running
from this nemesis I was like why can't
Resident Evil movies be this intense
I can't they be this good it's like doom
why can't they make a proper doom movie
why can't they make a proper Resident
Evil movie but as these Resident Evil
remakes are essentially playable
Resident Evil movies I guess this is
good this is fine I also like the fact
that it bounces from Jill to this guy
named Carlos he actually works for
umbrella but he's not a dick I mean
umbrella the corporation they're dicks
but he seems to be a good guy I like the
fact that this person's figuring out
that hey maybe the company I work for
maybe they're not good I just like the
fact that it emphasized that not
everyone who works for dickbag companies
are dickbags themselves this kind of how
life is and like the Resident Evil 2
remake the dasam bees still have that
rubber head [ __ ] intermittent head
bob so you're like I mean you run into
that because you're trying to conserve
ammo as the Resident Evil game can't
just take a shotgun blast to a zombie
you gotta save that for the difficult
enemy sometimes you're like you know
what screw it
[ __ ] you the game has the Resident Evil
three dodge mechanic you can jump back
and dodge from a zombie though zombie
you do lunge that used to suck sometimes
it works so if you time it right you
will dodge past them under their arms
though if you're Carlos you don't just
dodge you Neil punch them in the chest
but I like that that whole dodge
mechanic gives a little more complexity
to the gameplay when you get that dodge
mechanic down you feel like a badass a
[ __ ] kind of
anyway I mean I was having fun with this
game I was along for the ride until at a
point in the last act I was like I'm in
a lab that that's Resident Evil for you
at the end of the game how long is this
game rather short which kind of shows
the genius of Resident Evil 2 the
PlayStation 1 original and the remake
they were like we can have a game and
then you can play as another character
in which their past lets have different
areas but a lot of the same map is the
other person then you can take them and
swap their paths and basically if you
play the same path through another
character's eyes it feels like you're
experiencing a new game or at least a
new experience because new characters
new eyes it feels new very smart way for
gamers to get more gameplay hours out of
a game this game is more linear yes you
do jump over to Carlos's perspective but
it's not like you ever swapped Jill for
Carlos and you play the different paths
now the game just kind of it plays out
and and then it's done and it definitely
does feel a lot shorter than Resident
Evil 2 I mean I beat the game in seven
hours but that's me sniffing around
trying to get every piece of ammo and
you know I wanted to get everything cuz
it's a Resident Evil game you need that
ammo I mean yeah if you want to farm all
the trophies you're gonna play through
this game a lot more than someone who
just plays through the story but any
games like that for comparison's sake
the Resident Evil three remakes about as
long as the spider-man game for ps4 DLC
I wouldn't pay 60 bucks for Spider Man
DLC and that's what this feels like this
feels like Resident Evil 2 DLC Resident
Evil 2.5 and there are even some zones
in the original resident evil 3 nemesis
game that aren't in the Resident Evil
three remake it's like why would you do
that why would you take an already short
game and make it shorter for your remake
like if you look at uncharted Lost
legacy it was like what was it DLCs or
remake what is it reports are it started
out as DLC but then became its own games
alright we're just gonna make it at
something and we'll sell it separately
again believe Uncharted Lost legacy is
longer than Resident Evil 3 but also
they sold Uncharted Lost legacy at 40
bucks when it was brand new but you can
make the argument if it games five hours
long but feels like 15 did you get your
money's worth because it feels like a
full game or if it games 15 hours long
but feels like five you still get your
money's worth you know perspective but
this game took me seven hours and it
felt like seven hours but it's not just
game play length like the Resident Evil
to remake took mr. X and they just made
him a force to be reckoned with
they made him a constant threat you can
always hear him walking through the
police station those footsteps were just
too good doom could turn you felt like
you were in a quiet place the movie just
like they took an enemy from the
original who showed up at certain
designated times for an ammo sink sub
boss fight moment and they made him a
constant threat who's always patrolling
this police station it made him feel
alive it made it feel like the threat
was always there always coming after you
when you heard him behind the doors
alright maybe I'll take another route to
get around it was amazing so with
Nemesis I wanted to see how they were
gonna do that with Nemesis and they're
really good no he shows up and he's
chasing your ass though for the first
couple of encounters if you damaged him
enough I suggest one grenade that'll
drop him to a knee he drops a gun
upgrade for you get that it's well worth
it longer name but he basically chases
you it's like he's like a dog hurting
you like an Australian Shepherd hurting
you to the next area
it is cool if you go into another shop
that you're not supposed to go into he's
right outside the window just looking at
you're like oh I don't want to go
outside I actually went to the wrong
area and I was like okay maybe I can go
out there maybe he's not oh my god he is
that was pretty intense but really that
ends when you get to the next own you
need to get to like alright now you're
there and then you'll run into the
nemesis again who chases you again you
get to the next own sweet he's gone or
you got to fight him for a second and
then he's gone twenties he did not feel
nearly as present in this game as mr. X
did in Resident Evil 2 remake mr. X was
elevated to be an enemy that you may or
may not run into at any corner you round
it made him very unpredictable with
nemesis you run into him at designated
predetermined very specific times which
is undeniably that's a step back between
that some of the zones from the original
game not being in this game I feel like
they were like we really want this game
to come out a year after the last one so
we could speed up that process let's do
it which is fine but in the competitive
world of games you got a price that [ __ ]
accordingly and as fun as I had playing
this game I can't justify the $60 price
tag I'm gonna say this game is
definitely worth getting at sale price
right so the remake of Resident Evil 3
have you played it why did you think
about it how does it compare to the
original game are you having a blast
with it do you think it's worth
60 bucks whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]